So anyway,
so there's Horace and then there's the guy on the,
on the right there is set and he's like the precursor of the Christian
representation of Satan.
In fact,
the named Satan seems to have been at transformation of the name sat and Psat is
actually,
he's like the God of totalitarian possibility because in Egypt in mythology he
represents the brother,
the evil brother of the rightful king who's always plotting to overthrow the
rightful king.
And Horace is his natural enemy.
And what this means,
I tell you man,
it's really important.
So I have in my clinical practice frequently people who are stuck in the middle
of absolutely moronic bureaucracy.
So I can give you an example of this.
I just love this.
One of my clients who worked for a large corporation,
who's pretty sensible woman,
she's being driven mad by the political correctness that didn't detected the
organization.
And she sent me at 32 32 email letter exchanges that were circulating around the
word flip chart.
I don't know if any of you have heard the flip chart conver controversy,
but it's Kurt pretty mind bogglingly moronic.
And,
and so the deal was that somebody,
you know what a flip chart is,
right?
It's one of those paper pads that you flip the paper over.
Well it turns out hypothetically that flip is a pejorative term for Filipinos.
And so they believe that the idea,
the flip chart phrase was no longer acceptable because it was potentially
offensive to was,
although I bet they would have had to like vacuum up the whole planet to find
one Filipino who actually cared whether or not someone called that a flip chart,
you know?
And that person would have had plenty of problems that were worse than that.
Anyway,
there was like a 32 serious email exchanges about what terminology should be
used instead of flip chart,
you know.
So that's what people were doing instead of trying to actually have a life and
do something useful and it was driving her completely mad.
They did rename them and made it,
um,
it made part of corporate policy that it was inappropriate to use the word flip
chart.
I don't remember what the hell they called them.
Who knows?
But,
but the reason I'm telling you this story is lot of you are going to find
yourself embedded in bureaucracies and you know,
and there's that for better or for worse.
And one of the things that are going to,
is going to happen to you is that people are going to ask you to do stupid and
ridiculous things.
And the fact that they're asking you to do stupid and ridiculous things,
it's going to do two things,
three things to you.
One is it a warp you so that you'll pretend that you agree with it and then
eventually you will,
and like good so much for your soul.
And then the other thing is,
is that it will demotivate you because you'll think,
why should I be like slaving away at this job when you know I'm being pecked to
death by morons with stupid rules.
And um,
the third thing that it will do is make you resentful and irritated,
and then that will also undermine motivation and make your life miserable.
And so you might think,
well,
what should you do about that?
And the answer to that is you should object at the earliest possible point
because first of all,
you'll find that if you do,
if you object to radical stupidity,
when it first emerges,
you kind of make people aware of the fact that what they're doing is radically
stupid and they'll usually back off.
And so then they won't torture you to death.
So,
you know,
you have to take a risk,
which is,
oh no,
what happens if I complain about this?
But you know,
it's another one of those situations where you're damned if you do and you're
damned if you don't.
So if you complain,
that'll cause some trouble.
Although usually it causes way less trouble than you'd think because people are
generally not very courageous.
And if you push them with some strength on a,
when they're doing something absolutely moronic,
they'll usually back off because they don't know what to do when they're being
challenged.
And then you won't have to put up with it for the rest of your life.
And so why I'm telling you this is because all sorts of bureaucratic,
uh,
entities,
corporations,
government institutions,
um,
nonprofit organizations,
anything that's above a certain size,
cause it doesn't matter if it's government or corporate,
it's all the same bloody foolishness.
When it gets too big,
it's like those things can towards totalitarian structures.
It's part of,
it's part of their,
the innate danger that's associated with social organization.
And so then you might say,
well how do you keep the enterprise that you're part of alive and dynamic and
also keep it a place that a sensible person who's got,
who's got a proper orientation could stand to work.
And the answer is do not do things.
You know,
to be stupid.
Stand up and say,
look,
that's dumb.
I'm not doing it.
And if they ask you why,
then you can say,
well,
hey,
I think it's stupid B,
if I do it,
I'm going to get irritated and resentful.
And also if I do it,
it's going to decrease my motivation so I'm not doing it.
And then if they push you too hard,
it's like,
hey,
it's time for a different job.
And that might be the best thing that ever happened to you because if the,
the structure you're in is going in that direction and you can't stop it,
it's like get the hell out of there and find something else.
So it's not that hard to find a job when you already have a job.
Now it's another thing to keep in mind too,
you know,
when ever you're working and you will be,
especially in the world that the world of today where jobs are relatively
uncertain is you should always have an escape route plant and it should be
active because if you don't have an escape route and you can't get away,
you can't say no.
And if you can't say no,
you can't bargain.
And if you can't bargain,
you're a slave.
So those,
that's how it,
that's how the world is set out at the moment.
Probably always been like that.
But it's something that you really need to know cause you got to watch if
you're,
if you're being is objecting to someone to something that someone is forcing you
to do,
maybe you're right,
maybe you shouldn't be doing it.
And lots of people end up living meaningless lives and that that's,
that's not a very good term because there's no such thing as a meaningless life
because one of the meanings of life is suffering and there's no bloody way
you're going to escape that.
So you will not have a meaningless life.
You'll have a life that's only suffering.
And I wouldn't recommend that because it'll make you one miserable creature and
plus you warp everyone around you because you'll be vengeful.
So it,
these things are really important.
They're really important.